[ Birds chirping ]
-General...thank you
for seeing me.
-I figured if there was anyone
who could make sense of
this mess, it would be you.
-Hello, Neo.
-I know you.
-I've tried to keep
my eye on you.
-Oh, beautiful sunset,
beautiful sunset.
-That was the sunset.
-It was worth it.
So, that was a clip
from "Matrix Resurrections."
And I would imagine
one of the things
with a film like that
is keeping things secret.
-Mm-hmm.
-And did you have a lot of
people trying to get it
out of you or did they respect
that that was something
they couldn't tell you?
-Actually, I think everyone
is so terrified --
or everyone in my vicinity
understands that,
that nobody
really asked me anything.
Nobody asked me.
Everyone was excited,
but nobody asked me.
I remember,
when I got the script,
which was the first time
I met Lana Wachowski,
who's, like, a very --
You know, she's a massive
filmmaker and prolific,
and it was intimidating.
And when she gave me
the script for the first time,
freshly printed
with my name on it,
she said,
"Welcome to the Matrix."
I remember -- I was like --
And then I took it
and I put it in a vault.
And I swear to God,
I would probably read it
under covers with,
like, a torch.
"Is anybody watching?"
-That's good.
You took it seriously.
I did.
-You also -- You just shot a
show in London called "Citadel."
-Yes.
-Tell us a little bit
about that.
-Oh, that's really cool.
It's for Amazon Prime Video.
And it's the Russo brothers,
and it's with Richard Madden,
Stanley Tucci.
It's really cool.
I get to do lots of stunts.
It's a little bit
of a dystopian future.
I'm an international superspy.
-That's perfect.
I want to also ask you,
because, obviously,
you take care of yourself
and you have a lot of, like --
sort of a self-care regime that
maybe we might not know about,
including something
with beer and eggs.
Tell us what it is
and where you learned it.
-Okay, the Indians would know
about this, by the way.
-Oh, interesting.
-It is, it is.
Or at least my mom
claimed that that was true,
and then I saw her
friends do it, too.
But, apparently, beer and eggs,
which my mom used to do
when I was growing up,
in her hair,
and she'd leave it as
a conditioner.
And, apparently,
it's really good for you.
It helps with growth,
hair growth.
And it stinks to high heaven,
but when she shampoos it,
it's alright.
-Alright, interesting.
So, do you, like, sort of whip
the egg and then pour a beer in?
-No, it's not so complicated.
-Okay.
-Just mix it, put the beer in,
you know,
try to not get it everywhere.
-I feel like you're pranking me,
but I'm gonna do it.
-Google it. I promise you.
-Google it. Alright, sure.
[ Laughter ]
I know you tried to pick up,
like all of us,
pandemic hobbies,
including painting.
Are you still actively painting
or have you moved on,
found anything else?
-It lasted two days.
I painted,
I learned cross-stitch,
which was for two days.
I bought a drum set,
'cause I was like,
"I'm gonna do this."
-Oh, no.
-Never sat on it.
-Priyanka, no.
-It has my jackets, my clothes.
It looks really great.
So, many, many hobbies --
piano, knitting.
I knitted the front half
of a sweater.
-Oh, that's wonderful.
So like a bib. You made a bib?
-Sort of.
-Yeah, yeah.
-And it's the size
of my husband's chest,
so it's substantial work,
by the way.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah, of course.
-And, so, I didn't really
end up doing very much.
But I wrote a book.
I launched a hair-care line.
-Oh, yeah, Beer and Eggs.
-Yes, Beer and Eggs.
[ Laughter ]
-I saw that at the store.
I was wondering.
-It's a good name.
-Yeah, it is a really good name.
It was a do-it-yourself kit.
It was just, like,
some Coors Light
next to a dozen eggs, yeah.
-There you go. That would sell.
-That would sell.
I mean, that's my favorite --
beer and eggs.
-Right?
I want to ask, as well,
you kind of came up
through the pageant world.
What was your first title
before Miss World?
-Miss India.
-Miss India, okay.
So you're Miss India
and Miss World.
And I'm always fascinated by the
fact that part of it is
asking these giant questions
that would not even be
fair questions to ask, you know,
established adults onstage.
Was that the most terrifying
part of it for you,
knowing those were coming?
-I think once I stumbled upon
the Miss India pageant --
Because my mom
thought I was pretty,
and ended up, like a joke,
sending in pictures.
And I actually got a call back.
So I was like, "Oh, this is a
great way of me, like,
skipping my 12th board exams,"
which are, like, serious.
So I was like,
"Yeah, let's go for a pageant,"
never having done it.
Won it. I was 17.
And then I think I just --
That's when the actress
in me was born.
I just took on the part of,
like, a pageant queen.
I used to speak like that.
I was very articulate at 17.
I had no idea what I was doing,
and it took me
many years, actually,
to sort of shed
the produced image of
who I thought I needed
to be at that age.
And I think, like, women have
these subconscious, like,
you know, things that are
subliminally put
into their minds,
which is, like,
this certain way
you have to speak.
And pageants kind of do that,
you know, fan that thing.
But it took me many years
to be able to shed that.
But it was very terrifying.
But I'll ask you my question
that I was asked for Miss India.
Let's see what
your answer is, yeah?
-Great.
-Alright.
My question was --
This is very "Matrix," actually,
"Blue pill or red pill?"
But "If ignorance is bliss,
then why seek knowledge?"
-Well, that's a
wonderful question.
[ Laughter ]
-Great way of buying time.
-And I don't want you to think
that I am buying time
from this answer,
because I value your time.
And I appreciate that this
is a timed answer
and that, at some point,
a bell will ring
and I won't have
to get where I was going.
'Cause I can
be bailed out, right, Priyanka?
-No. No, no, no.
-I can't.
-Millions are watching.
-Great. Add the pressure, guys.
-I would just say to all of you,
on behalf of all of you,
I think that you, too,
have forgotten the question.
And --
-Concentric circles.
And Miss America is Seth Meyers!
-Oh, my God! Thank you!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Hey, thank you so much
for being here.
It's always such
a pleasure talking to you.
Priyanka Chopra Jonas,
everybody!
"The Matrix Resurrections"
will be in theaters
and IMAX nationwide
and HBO Max December 22nd.